all right let's take a look
[Music]
Doctor Who time and we are getting ever
closer to the premiere of series 11 the
debut of the 13th doctor and the
beginning of the Chibnall era and people
have been asking me for a while what I
think about this cuz I put out my
initial impressions of when ship Noah
was first announced but I didn't have a
ton to say about it then and even as
time has gone on I haven't had a
particularly deep dive because looking
at the man's work it's hard to judge I
think it can be very difficult whenever
you're dealing with a writer who you
can't really tell looking up their stuff
that they were putting their own stamp
on the material like you look at Moffat
scripts back during the Russell T Davies
era and you go oh you can see the guy's
fingerprints all over this I didn't have
enough of a sense of Chibnall as a
writer to really know looking at the
episodes of Doctor Who that he had done
if these were really true to him as a
writer or were these more work-for-hire
work on assignments were these
storylines he was basically given and
then did the best he could with or were
they things he really cared about now my
understanding at this point of how much
of the writing process worked with with
Doctor Who under both Davies and Moffat
I think a little more so with Moffat
though was that oftentimes ideas would
get pitched and section out and then
assigned to writers so oftentimes
writers who weren't saying Moffat
themselves or like really huge names
like say Neil Gaiman they are the
writers often weren't you know doing an
idea that was truly original from them
they were given an idea and then did the
best that they could with it and from
what I can tell that was the case for
most if not all of chip Noel's Doctor
Who episodes so again it made things
difficult to judge so what I've decided
to do is I'm gonna take a look at all of
his work within the Doctor Who universe
which means I'm also gonna look at his
work on Torchwood because he actually
was a pretty seminal and you know
forward pushing voice in Torchwood he
wrote a lot of the episodes of the first
two series of that and a lot of the
important ones as well especially in
that second season so I'm gonna be
taking a look at all this and I thought
initially that I was gonna rank them you
know the way I have with Davies and with
Moffat but it doesn't feel right at this
point to be ranking this whole instead
I'm gonna go through these
chronologically in order of airing and
just sort of tackle them one at a time
and then sort of give my final thoughts
at the end so let's look back on Chris
Chibnall work to date on Doctor Who
related material and we kick things off
with Torchwood and the episode day one
and this has hey bad start because I
don't know about anybody else I don't
hear a tone of people talking great
things about the stuff so but I hate
this episode so much like to the point
that I seriously considered not
bothering watching the third episode I
hated almost everything about this so in
case you've been oh it's been a while
since you are Short's wood or if you
haven't watched Torchwood at all this is
the second episode of the first series
of Torchwood it is Gwen Cooper who's
sort of the new recruit her first day on
the job which is why it's called day one
and so the team is dealing with
basically a sex demon I mean it's an
alien but it might as well be its
possessing people it's driven by a
strong sexual need and basically this
entire episode felt like the show
beating you over the head with look how
mature we are of course mature in the
most superficial possible sense and that
there's a lot of sex and people swear
and it's more violent than Doctor Who
and somehow this juvenile version of
maturity is something that we're
supposed to be taking seriously but it
is just so empty and Hollow and
meaningless and like I said completely
beating you over the head
stuff that does not feel like it's
coming out of the story it's just shove
as much adult material as possible into
this episode let's show people that this
is different from the main show and they
did show that it was different they
showed that it was crap
now I I say that as if it's a blanket
statement that all towards food is crap
it's not
Torchwood can't be really good but man
this Jim doll is lucky that I didn't
realize he wrote this episode way back
when he was first announced to be taking
over Doctor Who I would've been way more
pessimistic at the time but how will I
think about it now well we'll see
because let's see how he picked up if he
got better
next episode from Jim gnaw on Torchwood
is cyber woman now this it's better than
day one except almost anything is better
than day one slamming my finger in a car
door is better than day one but it's not
great and the frustrating thing about
this one is the core idea of it is
really good so what we find out in this
one is that one of the members of the
Torchwood staff basically the most
innocuous of the me Anto we find out
that his girlfriend was partially but
not fully cyber converted during the
Cyberman invasion during the events of
army of ghosts and doomsday over on
Doctor Who now his girlfriend the
conversion was not complete so she's
kind of partway there and he's been
taking care of her and trying to figure
out a way to try and reverse this and
this is the episode where the rest of
the team discovers that he's been
housing this thing in their base of
operations and you know everything just
goes wrong so like that core idea is
pretty good there's two major problems
with it though the first is that it's
too early in the series this is the
fourth episode of the first series and
to be blunt about it at the time it
happened I didn't know Ianto enough to
have this feel like a betrayal the way
that it's supposed to the way that feels
to the other characters because they
knew him a heck of a lot better than I
did he had been a more
on character and a more innocuous
character I'm not saying I needed him to
be front and center prior to this you
could have it be that trusty background
character but it needed to have been
longer before they tried to do a rug
pull with them to make a comparison to
say Buffy the Vampire Slayer we it
wasn't until the second season of that
show that we got kind of a rug pull in
regards to Giles who was the stodgy
exposition you know solid rock
knowledgeable and moral rock of the show
and then in the second season we find
out oh he's got some nasty history and
it works there because we had a whole
season of just being oh we think we know
this guy and then finding out we don't
four episodes in that doesn't work so
that's the first major problem the
second one is the cyber woman herself
and honestly largely I think it's a
problem with design again I'm gonna
chalk this up to the real superficial
mature nature of Torchwood especially in
those early years and she just looks
goofy and stupid and sexualized in a
bizarre way I think it would have been
so much more disturbing and so much more
an indictment of Ianto and his frame of
mind if she didn't look mostly human if
she basically looked like a Cyberman but
he was still referring to her by her
human name and still caring for and
taeheon trying to take care of her like
she was still human but she didn't she
looked almost completely converted I
think that would have worked so much
better than this cheesy weird and I
again it's been a long time since I've
checked out other people's reactions to
Torchwood but I feel like the whole
cyber woman punching a pterodactyl
moment was heavily mocked and it should
have been yeah so step up from day one
but still this is not clicking yet
next episode written by Chibnall for
Torchwood countryside now we're starting
to get decent
this was one of the episodes the hatch
got me continuing to watch Torchwood
because I was really really on the fence
up to this episode I figured I was
probably gonna finish the first series
but I also thought I'm not gonna watch
any more after this
but then this episode happened and again
for folks who have more Torchwood the
Torchwood team goes out into the country
and they are investigating just
brutality horrible brutal murders that
and the reason they're there is because
it's so bad they're pretty sure that
it's alien involvement it's the fault of
the rift which is you know what they
keep an eye on and as it goes along we
find out no this is not aliens it's not
extraterrestrials it's just people
really really sick people and that was
and that this was an instance where this
was a rug pool that did work and it's
been only times as I've seen to my
memory I did call it a little bit before
the reveal but not way in advance to the
point that it totally wrecked the the
reveal or the episode but even sort of
realizing where it was going it still
worked because it it kind of goes
against what the show have been
presented as being about as a whole up
to that point and we're about halfway
through the first series by now so this
is a good time to try and pull rug pools
as opposed to only episode four so what
you've got is you've got to show that
head every episode has been about
extraterrestrials every single episode
exactly how it's going on it varies but
that's always what they're dealing with
so when they go in to deal with
something and it's not that it's like oh
oh that's right for all the hail Ian's
the show up on earth people are kind of
terrible or can be oh yeah that's right
isn't it and it was well delivered it
was it was fittingly brutal and this
this first season had and I think
several woman's a really good example
this had a difficult time balancing what
were frankly campy elements and it's
more serious mindedness when the show
eventually got a handle on being more
serious that is generally when it was
better as a show and I feel like this
was possibly the first episode that it
felt like the entire episode was
properly serious but they're like tiny
moments of levity tiny jokes but there's
nothing about the scenario that's funny
there's nothing about the imagery that
you would laugh at and this I feel like
was where we started to see what
Torchwood can be when it was done
properly with it with the mood that
worked for it so this was the first
piece of notably strong writing from
Chibnall in the Doctor Who universe so
moving it along we've got the end of
days which is the series finale for the
first series of Torchwood and it is
pretty good I this one I actually had to
go back and rewatch I had to reassess it
because unfortunately for me the problem
was I had I came back I didn't watch
Torchwood as it airs I came back to it
after you know I think I've gotten
through if not series four definitely
series three of Doctor Who which meant
that I knew jack came back and hooked up
with doctor again which is all stuff
that happens after the end of series 1
of Torchwood and knowing that Jack
survives this kind of takes the wind out
of the sails of the story a bit but
that's not the fault of this episode
that's my meta knowledge when I watched
it for the first time but it is an
escalation of what has gone on that fits
and it feels appropriate and it feeds
into Jack's immortality which is as much
of a curse as it is a blessing and that
is played really well and the way that
the villain sort of gets the the
characters to do what he wants them to
do in order to free this base it's
basically a death God from the rift it's
um it's it's a pretty harrowing and
exhilarating episode I think it's
possible that they over said would like
the design of Abaddon I think it's you
know
between the limitations of the CGI
budget and just the idea of this huge
thing that just gonna lumber over
Cardiff then again the idea that
anything that falls in its shadow just
drops dead that's kind of cool so maybe
they guess it kind of balances on that
point so while it's not perfect by any
means it it is a solid it is a solid
finale episode it is large scale it is
impactful it is rooted in the characters
as far as where it goes and the
emotional beats it hits and how it
resolves everything so again pretty
solid stuff from chip know we're gonna
move off of Torchwood to get onto his
first piece of Doctor Who writing 42 and
42 while it is better than Sleep No More
I tend to think of the two episodes in
conjunction with each other which is
that the gimmick doesn't really do
anything to elevate the material in the
case of Sleep No More which juvenile
didn't write I'm just using as a point
of reference that had first-person
perspective gimmick you know the
found-footage gimmick this has a real
time gimmick and it and it is a gimmick
it you know the the characters are
theoretically you know where they're
working against the clock and the clock
is counting down in real time but it
doesn't feel substantively different
from any other Doctor Who race against
the clocks in are the doctor races
against the clock a lot in a lot of
stories having the clock actually be to
the second accurate for a tick down
actually doesn't add a heck of a lot so
if we strip the gimmick out because it
is just a gimmick it doesn't really add
anything to the story it doesn't detract
either but it doesn't add anything so it
was an especially weird thing to
effectively name the episode after and
it I suppose is also possibly a
hitchhikers guide reference except that
for an episode with this tone in this
mood this is not the episode to be
making hitchhikers guide references and
but if we look at the rest of it it's
interesting in an odd way and you know
what maybe the gimmick was somewhat
detrimental it almost feels a little bit
rushed I feel like something with
because the the creature monster kind of
thing going on in this is not all that
dissimilar in terms of core visual
concept from the empty child but a big
part of what worked with the empty child
was that was a two-part story that had
room to breathe and you go stretches
without seeing it and it wasn't
breathing down your neck so then when it
showed up again you're like oh crap this
one because it is only one episode and
it is so fast-paced it feels like the
thing is always there and in a way that
kind of diminishes its threat to a
certain extent I feel which is a shame
because there is strong stuff in this
Tennant gives a fantastic performance in
this one and and there is you know some
really interesting ideas in terms of the
the messaging going on sort of the
environmental messaging that's that's at
the heart of this so it has some
elements that work but it doesn't quite
come together it's also got some
elements that are goofy like God like
the doors being opened by pub quiz
answers which it's not the worst idea
I've ever heard but again feels gimmicky
and unnecessary and a little bit dumb
next up we got to get back to Torchwood
Torchwood series to the last series that
Chibnall himself worked on and we got to
talk about Kiss Kiss Bang Bang god I
love this episode I love this episode of
Torchwood Oh much and unfortunately a
lot of ways that hurt the series because
I saw this episode and I thought this is
what I wanted from Torchwood yes this
series is gonna be everything I wanted
the per series to be and it wasn't and
series 2 was pretty much as uneven as
series 1 was not in all the same ways
but it kind of yo-yoed up and down about
as much but this first episode is great
so
Jack's back he's with his team that
hasn't seen him for a while he's getting
back in the saddle and James Marsters
spike buddy from Buffy is on this
episode and he and Captain Jack make out
and yes you better believe that's the
greatness friggin thing ever and just
the feeling the vibe in what this
episode also has to a certain degree and
it's just enough of it it's a sense of
fun because that was always one of my
big issues with Torchwood conceptually
as a show is it took Jack Harkness who
was a character initially kind of
defined by his swashbuckling
devil-may-care charm and made him really
broody and I'm not saying they didn't
narrative ly justify it I get why he is
that way but I don't think he be I don't
think he's as fun as I care I don't I
don't enjoy watching him as much when
he's broody and mopey but I feel like
this episode is one of the ones that
finds the balance between he's still
charming he's still fun to be around
he's still fun to watch but he's also
kind of damaged whereas the way that
series one tried to bring in fun was you
know superficial adult fun you know the
day one crap but this episode really
does feel like it because it had allows
Jack to give that winning smile to be
just fun to be around and to have her
moment you have his moments with with
James Marsters and at the same time not
feel like he's been softened not feel
like he's over his damaged so it this
was a really wonderful balance of the
elements that actually work on Torchwood
and I think it's far as single episodes
go I think it I would argue it's the
best episode of the entire show and so
from that lofty place we can only kind
of go down not hugely though I'm kind of
gonna talk about three episodes in a row
because it's basically the three
partners that make up the what I would
consider to be the finale of series 2 of
Torchwood
and that is adrift fragments and exit
wounds now there are things that work
hearing things that don't a bit like end
of days it hits the character notes
right it hits the emotional notes right
especially for the core cast and you
know with Jack and everything that he
gets poked through that second one
fragments especially we got you know a
deeper look at some of the background
and some of the origins of some of these
characters and I think that was really
important because some of them are dead
by the end of this and if we didn't take
the extra time to be sure we zeroed in
on the connections between them and the
humanity of them and the history of them
as people not just you know members of
this team then the deaths of some of
them and that very last episode would
not have been as impactful as in fact
they are at the same time there are a
couple of problems as well I'm not a
huge fan of the villain of this the
character of gray I don't like I don't
like his background I don't like his
motivation I consider them to be cliched
and kind of trite I don't feel like the
fact that he is Jack's brother feels
like it means anything it just kind of
is and it said like okay so it's his
brother that old chestnut
like finding out that somebody is
actually somebody's a relative at this
point I just think that's a twist that
very rarely means anything anymore and
as far as his motivation like this is a
guy I don't know how old he's supposed
to be but he's a guy who blames his
brother because of something that
happened to him when he was very very
young and like Jack wasn't able to
protect him
Jack didn't actively do anything Jack
lost track of him in an emergency trying
to get him out he let go of his hand for
a second and lost him
didn't mean to didn't intend to and
certainly did not do to this guy all
this
that happened to him as a result of him
getting captured by these horrendous
creatures but he's gonna blame him
anyway and I just I almost never buy
that I hated when they pulled that kind
of crap motivation for friggin Blofeld
inspector one of the many reasons I
hated that movie so like I just I'm not
saying that it's impossible for me to
believe that there are people who can't
let a childhood issue go to the extent
that they would basically devote the
entire rest of their life to making the
person they hold responsible pay for it
I could buy that I've seen enough stuff
in my life that I could buy that that
that's possible but it's not interesting
it's not it's it's a very superficial
motivation I mean it I just I almost
never buy it
and I didn't really buy it here so
unfortunately the falldown of the of
these three episodes is the villain
doesn't really work for me
but the main cast though is all working
and the progression is working and the
impact of the villain is having on the
story in the main cast
that's all work is just the villain
himself as a character not as a plot
function as a plot function he's fine
but as a character I just I don't buy
him maybe part of its the the actor as
well maybe a better actor could have
sold it in a way that this guy didn't
cuz I just felt like I was getting
nothing often well that wraps up
Chibnall
Torchwood work so we've got a couple
more Doctor Who's to talk about we've
got the site Lorien two-parter the
hungry earth and cold blood so this is a
pretty solid episode it's not phenomenal
but it remains true to the heart of the
original concept of the Silurians from
classic who not just in terms of what
they are and that but also in terms of
what tends to happen to them if you if
you've never seen classic air
Seiler Ian episodes the the trend the
the first of all you have to realize the
Silurians have a legitimate claim to the
planet they were here first and then
beyond that they just there's always an
attempt at peace and it never works and
they end up getting wiped out now in
this case they finally don't don't get
wiped out but you are still feeling the
recurrence of God we were so close to
finally dealing with this and again they
just the salary's cannot catch a break
and i feel like that was well captured
in the in this and in terms of the death
of worry the the death that at least for
a little while stuck that was pretty
well handled it wasn't especially well
integrated as an element of the of this
story didn't feel like a like it was
complement like it was complementing
what the story had been doing it felt
kind of tacked on at the end but it
still worked still worked for what it
was and you know I like the star-lords I
like the visualization of them I like
the concept behind them and how they
their society appears to work and and
all of that so I do enjoy this episode
again it's not phenomenal but as far as
revival of classic era creatures go it's
a pretty decent one not great but good
next up dinosaurs on a spaceship I
actually really like this episode I
think it's a lot of fun I know a lot of
people don't I I think they just
consider it too silly which I mean I can
get there are times that I do feel
doctor who gets too silly for its own
good I do and I do enjoy this one though
I like the adventure vibe of it I like
the I there there's probably too many of
them but I do like the supporting cast
and you know we've got a Egyptian queen
and a big-game hunter you know people
who obviously have a history with the
doctor we've got Rory's
dad who's kind of adorable we've got
dinosaurs on a spaceship we've got the
bickering robots who I love you want to
talk about actual decent tribute to
Douglas Adams these sorts these sort of
bickering robots that feels very Douglas
Adams desk so I enjoyed them a lot the
closing note with Solomon and the way it
ends is it's not completely out of place
and it's not as jarring as some of the
gear as some of the tonal gear shifts
that didn't work in Torchwood some of
the early ones but it is a bit of a
shift from this you know good fun time
to oh the doctors kind of kind of killed
somebody okay seems like a like a bit
much but like I said even though it
doesn't I'm not sure quite makes that
transition it's not nearly as jarring as
as it could have been so this this for
me is one that's just a lot of fun again
it's no it's no great brilliant episode
but I find it quite enjoyable it's light
fluff and finally last episode written
by Chris Chibnall because yeah he has
not written nearly as many of episodes
of Doctor Who itself as you would flop
but let's talk about the power of three
which is a pretty heavily maligned
episode and again one that I think is
better than a lot of people give it
credit for I think a lot of people hold
the conclusion and the wrap-up of this
episode against the rest of it and I'm
not gonna say that's an invalid thing to
do because it really fails to stick the
landing the ending is very rushed and
not explained exceptionally well and the
ideas that are in it seem way too big to
just be tossed together at this last
minute here what bits of it I could make
sense out of it does just seem like the
the idea for the bulk of the episode is
one thing and then the conclusion is
almost like it's a little pocket thing
and this doesn't work but this I'd
actually say for the most part does I
like the idea of both this slow invasion
you know these things just show up and
do not
and the idea of the doctor hanging out
waiting for them to do something kind of
going a little stir-crazy kind of
getting cabin fever by being stuck on
one planet for so long
I think that's a neat idea and I think
what it brought out of him as a
character this also got to be you know
we got some more time with with Rory's
dad which I enjoyed again because he's
just kind of adorable and so we we've
got a bit of that I like Amy and Rory in
general so that they're working for me
just the the build up I felt worked the
conclusion felt part it just it doesn't
it barely makes sense and what does make
sense feels like a bad fit for what came
before it and again there's part of me
that doesn't know how much to blame
Chibnall for that cuz I don't know how
much of this was he was given here's
what its gonna be you know by Moffat but
at the end of the day it's it was still
his job to weave together the build up
in the conclusion and they don't they
don't mess it's just kind of cruising
along and then runs into a tree
and that is the entirety of Chris
Chibnall contributions to Doctor Who up
to this point so I haven't talked about
all these what conclusions do I have
overall well I think it's slightly
troubling that what I consider to be his
best stuff was a done on Torchwood
because I think by far his best thing
that he that he's written for doctor who
was Kiss Kiss Bang Bang but the other
good ones from from there the three
parter finale for series 2 of that show
countryside like those were really good
pieces of work and they were first show
that was Doctor Who related but wasn't
doctor who was very different tone wise
and were also a while ago his work on
Doctor Who itself tops out depending on
your on your sort of thinking and your
mentalities his best work is probably II
the Silurian two-parter or dinosaurs on
a spaceship to spend depending on
whether or not you could roll with the
fun of that I know again I know some
people hate it or you know what either
one
neither is great
neither is brilliant they're both good
even forty two is is decent but his
highs aren't that high and his lows are
pretty low that said his absolute worst
material the dredges of his output was
the very first stuff he was writing day
one and cyber woman are painful they're
really really bad but he it does look
like he got the worst of his stuff out
of his system when he started and he was
better after that not always at the same
level and and his highest levels seem to
have been with a different show so if I
were to extrapolate from this I would my
concerns and this is not me saying this
is what will happen cuz even even you
know taking all this into account he has
not written for Doctor Who in a long
time he didn't write it all for it
during Capaldi Zaire he was off doing
broadchurch and his own stuff so it's
been a while regardless but if I'm
looking at this output I would say my
concern is whether he has adjustable
enough to be able to blend elements and
tone and mood that is fitting for Doctor
Who or if he's going to shift the tone
of the show to be more in line with what
it was on Torchwood which he seemed to
be a little bit more at home writing and
have a better handle on once he got over
the stumbling blocks of the first two
episodes he wrote and that I do not want
that I do not want darker who to ever
adopt the tone of Torchwood and you know
I brought churches something that I I I
have only seen a little of I am working
my way through I'm God kind of deal with
that a little bit later down the line
but from what I've seen of it you know
knowing how seriously minded
I do worry to a certain degree about his
ability to capture the fun of Doctor Who
and I know he's not incapable of that
because like I said dinosaurs on a
spaceship is great fun but there are
also times where his use of fun really
clashes with more serious moments I
think the power of three is a decent
example of that so looking at his output
overall there are a lot of reasons to be
concerned but I also do see a writer who
seems to at least try to learn from his
mistakes like the horrendous issues that
exist in day one and cyber woman don't
recur again after that those problems
got left behind pretty much after that
and you know the the gimmick of 42 he
doesn't feel like elements are as tacked
on at least if they are they feel like
they would have been men like Rory
having to die at the end of the selarón
two-parter I'm pretty sure this was just
the point the series where that needed
to happen so yeah it's a little tacked
on but that's probably because it was
literally tacked on and I wouldn't blame
Chibnall for that so I feel like I look
at not only what he's written but the
order in which it came out and I feel
like I see a writer who isn't just
trying to impose what he thinks works
onto the material I feel like I see a
writer who try something and adjusts
after that which is a good thing what it
could feasibly mean is we start out
rough and get better
depending on how solid his starting
place is with Doctor Who once he gets
there but we'll see so that's sort of my
breakdown in my own personal thoughts on
all the Doctor Who related material that
Chris Chibnall has written what are your
thoughts on some more any or all of
these episodes what do you think about
what Chibnall may or may not be bringing
to Doctor Who as showrunner when that
starts up later this year whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe and
support me on patreon a follow me on
Twitter and links for all that stuff and
much more is down in the description
right there so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]